you must push Back Against the Machine
however you can do it in your own life
and especially if you're a politician or
a pundit you must not give the machine
What It Wants You must call out the
nonsense so here's a really nice moment
from over the weekend uh Glenn Younkin
who is the governor of Virginia and as
you guys know he was not going to be the
governor of Virginia when polls came out
only a few weeks before he was losing he
was not going to win and then he started
going after the woke stuff and he
started making sure that kids were going
to be protected in school and they
weren't going to pull all this trans
nonsense and all of that and then he
ended up winning well he was on Jake
tapper's show over the weekend and you
can watch how Jake tries to get him I
mean just heavy-handed nonsense and
Glenn Younkin comes back with how about
some of that uh sanity is he playing
because he just released it this week at
Scales back Virginia's wind and solar
energy emphasis instead focuses on
nuclear power economic competition but I
wonder if the events in your first year
as Governor the more and intense
hurricanes which scientists say they're
more intense because of climate change
the war in Ukraine and this week's OPEC
decision making the insecurity of where
we get our fuel from uh highlighted
doesn't that suggest that you should be
that we should be leaning into more
green energy not less well to be clear
what I what I've called for is an all of
the above and in fact it's not reducing
an emphasis on Renewables wind and solar
it's correcting an error that was made
in the previous administration's energy
plan which was to exclude everything
else and so we need to yes move forward
with wind and solar we need to move
forward with carbon capture and natural
gas we need to move forward with nuclear
and one of the things that I believe is
that we have a great opportunity in
Virginia to lead the nation in the
development of small modular reactors in
nuclear in order to provide base load
power that's clean and reliable and
affordable and this is why Common Sense
has to come back into this equation
which is we we can't evacuate one of our
strengths which is the fact that we
innovate in America we can in fact find
a way that natural gas can continue to
be a huge part of our overall power
stack we can innovate across nuclear and
we can Embrace Renewables like wind and
solar but we're going to have to adopt
all of them in order to get where we
want to be which is reliable affordable
and a clean power stack
ain't it great when people who know what
they're talking about and have thought
the issues through actually State their
case clearly sure we can do some of the
green stuff we can do some wind stuff we
can do some water stuff we can do some
nuclear stuff there's other things that
we have to do we can't ignore fossil
fuels let's do these things in tandem
Jake who unfortunately you know he's a
Democrat he's just a Democrat act that
is pretending to be a journalist so he
mentions all this and shouldn't we be
green it doesn't mean any shouldn't we
be green it would be nice a weird Kermit
the Frog let's be green and then Junkin
just comes in and says uh well actually
uh there's a lot of ways to skin a cat
and we're not going to destroy the
economy in the name of you know the
green new deal so I just thought that
was a really nice moment and I think
what's going to happen is more and more
people are going to realize that they
will have a Breaking Point with all of
this and perhaps the ultimate
realization of that will be hopefully a
giant red wave when it comes to the
midterms we we shall see